hey guys come on in take your shoes off
relax
no seriously remove your shoes and put
them in the designated cubbies please
this place is probably really
aspirational for you guys but if you
work hard enough one day you too could
have a luxury pre 9/11 style condominium
with optional built-in shelving is that
the clock yeah that's the one
but before we get to that I would love
to give you two the tour this is the
bedroom
pretty standard I like to kind of peek
out the windows and buy my neighbors
here a little bit this controls the
temperature of the room for the most
part I'm sure you guys are familiar with
that technology where's the bed don't
ask questions you don't want the answer
to and this is my Berg room Matt please
don't do that
you'll confuse them and here is the
reason you're here isn't she a beaut
what it's a it's a grandfather clock so
he's a beaut you know guys let's not
gender the clock okay it's a beaut so
where are we moving this genderless
Butte Humphrey one two lift their knees
mat with your knees lift with your knees
please please don't scratch the leather
that is real okay Fred that needle yep
yep yep yep yep yep yep yup do you guys
want a person oh I don't know it was a
slide back in for one second I just want
to hear is that it I'm watching TV what
time is it I'm not wearing my watch oh
it's 3:30 mmm you know what it's pretty
helpful to see it in context do you like
you're just so like a dinner party and
you're a little tired and you're a
vegetarian you guys are just chatting
it's nice being here at this dinner
party but I guess I'm just a little
tired I can't eat any of the meat stand
mm so you guys came over to watch the
game your team won your team lost but
it's just sort of something to talk
about well it's great news than my team
won the game well my team lost some I'm
ed I'm on the fence and I'm pissed my
team lost so you're at a breakfast party
and you both want the last biscuit oh I
thought that night did you want I mean
I've had a couple but I thought I
haven't had any biscuits thus far you've
been waiting up all night for him to
come home it's 2:00 a.m. and you
smelling perfume what the hell I got it
okay
lift on three one two lift yeah come on
this way Jake with your knees buddy you
turn it turn it turn it keep going
please be careful Matt for God's sake
yeah sometimes you got to go all the way
around the world to realize that home is
the only place you want to be I got a
splinter thank you guys so much I really
appreciate it
thank you for helping me out as a thank
you you have to let me take you to
dinner oh that's really nice of you to
offer but I'm not really much of an
eater yeah it's done don't eat okay I am
taking you guys to dinner and I will not
take no for an answer
plus you gotta get your parking
validated not cheap I'll grab your shoes
from the Cubbies
[Music]